hey guys you know this there's a lot of
craziness that's going on in the world
right now in Ephesians 5 says do not
take any part in an unfruitful work of
evil of Darkness but instead expose them
so I want to ask all of you who say that
you are reborn Christians
what are you doing
should we not overcome evil with good
too many of you are doing nothing
but the Bible says that we should shine
our lights
but too many of you are hiding and not
doing anything
so I want to encourage you not to just
be hearers of the word but to be doers
of the word obey God's word stand for
the truth in love and in the spirit
that's my message to you today